[音楽]
[拍手]
みなさんこんにちは
大谷拓哉と申します
前回第一回目の時には裏方としていつも舞台袖に耐え
なんか
感慨深いものがあります自宅のみなさんありがとうございますそして今日お集まりの
みなさんありがとうございます
しばらくお付き合いください
私が今日お話しするのは見えない体験から見えること
見えるんだか見えないんだかよくわからないですが
しばらくちょっとお付き合い頂きたいと
思います
まず皆さんに質問します
運動をするのが好きだという方体を動かすの好きだという方いらっしゃいますか
ありがとうございます
健康のために体を動かしているという方もいらっしゃいますか
大勢いらっしゃいますねありがとうございます
健康と運動というのはもう切っても切り離せないものだという風に考えています
中には
まあ運動ってのは気持ちいいです汗をかきます汗をかいた後の一杯がやめられない
なんていう人もいらっしゃるかもしれません
現在私は
信州伴奏バンコ協会 guiding star というところの代表をしております
どういう団体かというと知覚障害の方の運動着替え
一緒に歩いたり走ったりするそういう時間を設けたりとか
そのガイドをしてくださる人たちを
一緒にます育てていく
たくさん集めるそういうことをやっています
早速ですけれども
言えない体験見えない状態というのがどんなものかということを
ちょっと皆さんに観ていただきたいというふうに思います
それでは司会の古畑さんちょっとこちらまで行っていただけますでしょうか
はい失礼致します
お願いしますよろしくお願い致しますよろしくお願い致します
ではこのアイマスクを付けていただけますはいアイマスクですねじゃあますもあまり
効果いいですなー少ない思っちゃう
しっかりあの目をつぶっておいていただきたいと思います
書いちゃ
です最高はいはいって
左手をですね私の方にはいどこでしょうコレですねはい
ずいぶん低いところにあると思います私の方はこれです
でちょっと歩きますよ入ってはちょっと歩きましょうみーの方で歩いていきます
このスタイルというのは一般に視覚障害者の方を案内する時のものです
b は正面を向きましたね
これですと
私が沈んだ分だけ段差がある低い段差がある
上がった分だけ高い段差がある階段とかそういうのが分かるようになっています
あの決して前にですね見えないかとを送り出すようなことはしないでください
見えませんので
お願いします覚えておいていただければと思います
ではちょっと外していただいていいですか外していいですかはい
あっ違います
ってだけあそういうことを皆さんいらっしゃいませんハイキュー
では私先ほどの赤いカーペットのところに戻ります
はいこちらまでを一人で歩いて来ていただけますか
ひとりで歩いていけばいいんですねはいそして私は今正面を向いているんですよねそう
ですはいえーとじゃあこっちかな
案内ちょっとお待ちくださいそれ以上行くとですね
ぶつかってしまいますじゃあそこでアイマスクを外してみましょうん
はぁ大平すごくなれに明日さんちゃったじゃあこちらまでいただいて
だいぶ方が害金違ってますねそうですね
はいえーと歩きだしはいかがでしたか歩き出すときはまだいいんですけれども
2本目を踏み出すあたりで若干恐怖が動きましてね中これアイマスクとちゃっていい
ですか
結構ですあれ
いうか怪しい感じになっても白いたしますありがとうございます
怖いん
怖かったそうですね枚とに
まだ立ってる段階では正面向いているというのが分かったんですかよそれがいざ横向い
たとき
者が本当に横向いてるのかもちょっとわからずですね歩きだしはまあ1本目はまだいい
んですけど
2本目になるとちょっとふらつくという現状もありましてはい
はいこういう形ですね
ありがとうございましたもうこれだけで結構ですはいありがとうございましたがとう
ございましたありがとうございますお取りください
[拍手]
観ていただいた通り
まあお聞きいただいた通り見えないということは
怖い
非常に恐怖が伴います
実際これらのまあしょうがないとも言えますなぜか
近くっていうのは人間には五感
感覚がありますそのうちの87%が死角から来ているというふうに言われています
約9割
それがいきなり遮断されてしまう
見えない状態で歩いてくださいと言われても
強いのは当たり前ですも仕方ありません
もう一つ今回皆さんと一緒に
見えない退店やってみたいと思います
8先ほどあのお聞きしました運動をするという方がけっこういらっしゃいましたよね
準備運動
されると思います準備運動の前の運動として関節
人間の関節をですね全部動かしておくといいよということを言われています
例えばマグーアークああ
手の指の関節ですねあとはひじ
万伸ばしたり曲げたり伸ばしたり曲げたりという運動
まあこういうことをやりますはいでは皆さん
目を閉じてください
目を閉じていただいて私が言うように運動をしていただきたいというふうに思います
愛ではまずてのグーパーやりましょう ua あ
ああしもクーパーやりましょううあー
ん足の指本ですね
相手校ですはいは
そんな目を閉じたままで今度は肘の曲げ伸ばしをやります
はい伸ばしてあげる伸ばしてあげる
伸ばして曲げる伸ばして曲げる
伸ばしてあげる
はいじゃあついでに
手首を増していきましょう配偶ぐるぐる得る
ぐるぐるぐるぐるはいありがとうございました目を開けていただいて結構です
今
ルーパーは特に問題なく皆さん同じ動きをしました
神の曲げ伸ばし皆さんが肘の曲げ伸ばしをやった時にはほとんどの形がこーされました
わたしそれをやっている時に肘の伸ばしたり曲げたり伸ばしたり曲げたり伸ばしたり
曲げたりというふうにやってました
維持の曲げ伸ばしはたくさんありますいろんな方法があります
なのに皆さんはこうされましたなぜでしょう
私が説明の時に
伸ばしたり曲げたりという風に説明した
皆さんはそれを目で見て覚えて肘の曲げ伸ばしはこうするものだという風に
思われたからです
何が分かるか
資格情報は大きいということです
87%のそれと同じことがいえるというふうに思います
視覚情報ということで
いろんなことをやっていますこれは10月の中旬に上高地へ行った時の写真です
視覚障害者の方3名と一緒に行きました
ここでも見えない体験行ってきました
風光明媚な上高地
景色を見に行ってるんじゃないのなんていうふうに言われることもあります
ただ見えない体験をやるとこうなります
ほうが高いですね太陽出てきましたとか
わー
うんを
この木はデカイですねー
え
これがこの木の葉っぱですか小さくてすべすべしてますね
匂いはう
いまいち
とか
あれ川の音が大きくなってきましたねー
風も感じる
気がなくなってきたから広いところに出ましたか
とか
見えない分
他の感覚がすごい鋭くなって
いろんな発見があったり
いろいろさまざまに感じる
感動が増えるんです
見えない体験をやると感動が増えます
この写真は
一昨年
全国障害者スポーツ大会というところで走った時のものです
ドラッグ境に陸上競技ですね1500m
小林稔さん松本も学校の先生と一緒に走りました
白いロープを1メートルのロープを張ったにして
一緒に走ります
スピードを出すためには二人三脚のようにおはポ幅保町
腕の振るタイミング全部あわせます
競技者が他にもたくさんいらっしゃいますのでそこにぶつからないようにガイドは責任
があります
よし内の選手男
2秒見込み25よし抜いた
左入ってな邂逅な邂逅もったいないもっとな邂逅とかそんなこともやります
普段の練習もそうです i 水たまりあるからね見に行くよー
車きたねーちょっとここ狭いから1列になろうか
後ろに入ってもらいますそんなことを一緒にやります
普段の生活でもそうですまあ大会とかいきますと一緒に食事したりとか
お風呂入ったりとかそんなことなりますので
一緒にまあええ
食事で言って
お茶ここに置くねって言ってもここじゃわからないんですね
相手の手を持ってここに置くよっ知らせる
お皿の中に何が入ってるかそれはサビだよとだね
それをわざとわさび食わせたりとかしてそんなことをしますけれども
行かなきゃいけないん
お風呂具もそうです
座ったところでシャンプーリンスボディーソープ
シャンプーリンスボディーソープそういう順番で並んでるよ全部教えてあげます
小林さんに言うんですリース使うの
小林さんごめんなさい
でもそうやって生活もしていくと
私は相手のことを考えます
思いやりを持つ
小林さんは私を信じるしかない
相手を信じ
相手を信頼し
そしてこっちは彼のことを思いやる
見えない体験をやると
二思いやり
信頼関係というものが生まれてきます
どうでしょう
普段の生活の中でも信頼関係っていうのはあると思います
たとえば家族
パートナーとの信頼関係
職場
学校地域
いろんなところにコミュニティはあります
コミュニケーションをとるためのツールというのが信じる
思いやるというものだと思います
見えない体験はそれを体で感じることができます
ぜひやっていただきたいとそういうふうに感じます
あるとき私は小林さんに言われました
僕は大谷さんがいてくれるから汗をかいて気持ちよく走れるんですよ
なるほどと思いました
視覚障害を持っている形をどんどん外に出して足を書いてもらって風を感じてもらって
気持ちよくなってもらおう
そう思って協会を立ち上げました
結成走ることが良いことだと私は思っていません
走ることは求めません
みんなで楽しくおしゃべりしながら歩く
そして気持ちよく汗をかいて体
もしかしたらいっぱいある
そんなのが
できたらとってもいいなというふうに考えています
ある日の松本の街中での写真です
全く問題ないと思います
見えてる人には
幅もあります車椅子も取れるほどの肌があります
でも
黄色い線
電子ブロックです
いない方はこれを頼りに歩きます
白い杖白杖を持ってこうやって歩いた場合どうでしょう
おそらく自転車にぶつかってしまいますねぇ
時には薄情がスポークのところに刺さって薄情が折れてしまうこともあるそうです
私は思うんです
おそらく見えない体験をやって
相手のことを考えるようになれば
こういう自転車の止め方はなくなるんじゃないかな
そういう社会ができたらいいなそういうふうに思っています
何も上高地とかでまあ自然の中で見えない体験とってもいいんですけれども
そればっかりじゃなくて街中でやるのもいいなっていうふうに考えています
言えない体験街中探検隊
おそらく
皆さんやって見て見ていただくと面白いと思います私は想像がつくんですね
男ってこんなに眺めてるのとか
ちょっとした段差にどんあ
本当に3センチの段差でびっくりするくらい驚きます
そういうのをぜひ体験していただきたいそんな風に考えています
見えない体験をやって
強いす強さ
これをぜひ関していただきたいと思います
そして見えない体験をやって感覚を磨いていろんな感覚を使って感動を増やして
いただきたい
そういうふうに思います
見えない体験をやって
信頼信じる思いあるその気持ちをぜひ思い出していただきたい
そう思います
私の話は今日はこれで終わりです
最後に
川の音を聴いていただきたいと思います
皆さん目を閉じて川の音を聞いてください
[拍手]
情景を思い浮かべていただくのも結構です
今日を一緒に来ていただいた一緒に来た人
誰を思い浮かべていただいても結構です
[拍手]
その人に向かって
ありがとう
って言えるでしょ
[拍手]
言える方はぜひいただきたいです
言えない方
[拍手]
そんな言えない自分をいとおしいと思う降った
見えない体験をぜひ約みてください
[拍手]
今日はありがとうございました